hi
in this talk we are going to talk about
automating your headless cms with
graphql
so before we start a quick intro about
me
i'm nidhi kumari i'm a front-end
engineer at short trade i'm a google
summer google summer of code alumni you
can connect with me on twitter my
twitter handle is her 98 and my github
heidi is nikki
thank you jscont mexico for having me
here
now for the agenda of today's talk
first we'll talk about what is hitler
cms then we'll talk about a specific
kind of hedley cms called contentful
we will talk about graphql a little bit
and then
contentful and graphql how we can
connect them and then
we'll code together and we if you have
any questions
we will
answer that
so
next
if i have to put
or in my entire talk into one picture
this is going to be the picture we have
our data source which is a which is a
cms content fill here i'm going to
import the data from contentful via a
graphql api into my react based
application
so this sounds too simple i understand
but yeah let's
walk step by step so that we understand
it completely
now
what is headless cns
so
previously
we had
monolithic cmss which is like you we
used to put our images our html code
everything into one big bucket
now
since we modernized so much we have a
new approach called headless cms where
we separate the front end and the
content completely
so a headless cms unifies the entire
data into a single headless content hub
and it enables simultaneous
collaboration so if i am someone who had
to change a content but i don't want to
interrupt my friend in engineer so i'll
go there and i'll change the content in
contentful and it will be fetched into
my front end via queries just like it
was
so this is how it makes collaborative
platform for us
then it is a headless cms which
organizes the content
without a connected front end or where
we can organize the content without a
connected front-end or display layer
and then
the content from cms is delivered via
apis across different devices so
previously when we had when we did not
have headless cms we used to serve data
only on our web browsers but now since
we have uh
take changing day by day we have to
manage data for our variables or our
smartphones so that's where headless cms
kind of makes our task quite easier
so
now what is contentful
contentful is the api first content
management platform where you can create
the data manage the data and then
publish the data on any digital channel
sounds good
so the structure of contentful is we
have organizations for example i'm part
of shop trade so my organization is
going to be shop trade and in that
organization i can have multiple spaces
for my specific projects and then each
project can have environment a master
environment or whatever environment i'm
going to work with
then
now comes the two most important part in
contentful so i
need to have a content model
i need to have
a same page
for each of my clothes but i want like
i want to have like
one content model where i can just
create one model and i can go ahead and
change the content for each
page
so there i'll create a content model and
then i'll change the content of each
page with the content to understand it
better
we have our next slide where we'll take
a tour of contentful
so
once you go to the contentful side we
have this kind of site there
and you have to log in
and then you will be navigated to screen
like this here
we have talked about organization so you
can see
i have oops i have my organization test
here and there i have spaces
i am like we have spaces is the next
part so i have created talk space here
specifically for today's talk
and then we have content model where we
are going to continue create a content
model and then we are going to create
content so let's create a content model
i want a content model a blog post
blog post
created
now in this content model i need to have
a title
so to add new fields we have multiple
fields here wow we have rich text text
number date and time location media
where you can add your images videos
pdfs or any other files boolean a yes or
no value adjacent object and a reference
so i need to have a text
my title so i'll name it just title and
i don't think my title is anywhere going
to be moved into 55 words so i'll put it
as title here
then i apart from the title i need one
more field which is going to be
um
a description
so let's add a description
create one then i have to add
a media which is going to be my image
you can select
um single image one five or mini files
depending on what you need on that page
i need a single file so i'll go with
single image
let's
save it
now once you go to
once you have saved it and you can check
it there in the content model now you
have one content model which is blog
post
now let's create a content
to create a content
right now we have only added one content
model blog post that is why we have one
option here but if we have multiple
content models and you click you can see
them in the drop down list so let's add
our only content model here
and let's name it
block one
blog one
says hi
oh we can add no
now let's add a media
i'll go with add existing media since i
have added some media already
and i'll publish it
now we have our first blog post ready
now i'll have to add another i want to
add another blog post this is going to
be blog
and this should have
just
go that's awesome
now well i want to add another media
but let's add a new media here
so once you add a new idea we see there
we have options like title description
and a file so i can add a title
new media or whatever you want to add
here then we can open style selector you
can choose from any of the places where
you want to upload your image from it
can from a laptop a link
a web search facebook instagram drive
dropbox you can take a photo record a
video or record an audio
so let's add an image
i have this one image
so i'll add this one
then after uploading this image we need
to publish it we all the time we need to
publish the data
so
yeah we can publish it
and then we need to publish our blog
post too
so right now if you go to content you
can see you have your content
added
so
this is about like how you can manage
your data with contentful let's see what
we have in the next slide
we have graphql so graphql is a query
language for apis it provides a complete
and understand base comes with a graphql
schema based on its content model so
whatever model we are going to create we
will have a particular schema fixed for
that model and using the graphql api we
are going to fetch the data directly
from our contentful into our friend and
application
too much
so let's code it
so here
we have our blog post
which is ready now i have already added
a front end up here like i have created
this application using npx create react
app command so not nothing hard in
person then i have added some code which
you will get later on
so
here i can see to query a data i mean i
need to add an access token
i need to add a space id
and then
based on that access token in space id i
am going to make a fetch call to graphql
and
with that i'm going to get a data
i'm going to fetch the data and as
payload i'm going to pass this query
here
so
but i haven't talked
so to
connect with a specific front and
with specific content for model we need
to have an access token so for that you
need to go to the settings
api keys
and here you can add an api key
once your api key is ready
you can
just
get the space id there
paste it
then we have our
access token here again we need to paste
it
there
so
we have our friend in reading
but
i have this code already running
on my port 3000 but what i see here is
no albums defined it is because we
haven't added any query yet so let's go
to graphic ul which is an interface for
graphql here
sorry
and now if i just run it i'll see that
we have some errors because i haven't
added the access token
probably my accessories wrong
oh yes
so now since i have added it
and this is same
so
now let's query the data
to query the data
like
so we have our first blog post
collection that i already know because i
have created it then here
let's see how many
data we have like how many queries we
have so once you run it see here
using this url where you will pass the
space id and access token you can see
the data here
so
now apart let's fetch the actual data
which is our items
for each items
sorry
for each item
so here for each items i need to pass
some
data here so i need we have our title
then
apart from that title we have a
description and we have then added an
image so we have added an image
now
see
the image if you will leave it like this
it will start showing some errors
because as we know image is not empty
the image we have a few things like each
image of the title
and then we have
title description and then we have added
one more thing
which was the file name right
let's check it out
you can see like whatever it's file
so
you go there you can see the file name
then now you run it and you can see
we have our data here like
it's block two log one log one says hi
so js
mako is awesome
then we have title for our images and we
have our data
ready
on the graphic url and we can fetch the
data now to our front end so let's
use this data to get it into our front
end
so now what i will do i'll use this
entire query and pass this
into my front-end application here
so we can add it here
and save it
and now what we will do we will just
console this response in our friend
application
so here
what i can see
in my console
is
a blog post collection in the items i
have data
which is the description image title
so
now
we have
got um we have just consoled the data
here
now what we will do we will fetch this
data uh sorry we're going to use this
data i'll say state and then we are
going to use this data and display it in
our front-end application
well
now since we have our data here let's
get the data running oh it says it has a
problem
cannot read properties of undefined
deleting albums this is line number 57
yes because it's not album collection
it's blog post collection
so i'll take this from there
and i'll add it here
now
we can see our data
here
but
how is that so we have got the data we
have set state here
then in the render i guess we can ignore
this because this is just aerostate
handling
so i have fetched the data i have from
the state i have extracted blocks in the
blogs out of the blocks we have i have
run a map method
and i have
taken the blog.title
here here i have block.description
here
a blog.image.url
blog.image.description which we will use
here but
we can't see an image because we haven't
received the url yet
so
to get that let's add one more thing
here and we will see the url
of our image there so let's
go to that query
and add a url here
now if we go there we can see that we
have our images here
the ui does not look good but that is
certainly not our concern here
so
that is how you can fetch the data from
contentful into your react because
application
a few suggestions
we should not be adding our access token
directly like this instead it should be
in an env file and then we should fetch
it and i would advise you not to use
mine since by the time you will use it
it will be deleted from there
if you have any questions just reach out
to me
and if you have any problems related to
crafty well contentful just check out
the live site that's really amazing and
sorry for the ui so this is about
today's talk and
about me
let's see what we have in the slides so
here is the github repo where you can
get the code for this
project that i have built
then we have thank you for having me if
you have any questions just feel free to
reach out to me thank you